I I know I say it every week I could
have ser to get I think I know why the
Liberals are happy tonight
finally the Senate has confirmed
President Obama's choice for attorney
general Loretta Lynch after 165 days of
stonewalling and history is made she is
the first black woman Attorney General
in the United States and and not a
moment too soon
she's had her first priority in office
will be to free Ben Affleck slaves and I
think that's a great silly a scandal
I've ever heard but a lot of women in
the news this week Hillary is now not
the only woman running for president on
the Republican side Carly Fiorina has
thrown her hat in the ring
she is running as the junior senator
from California which is unique because
she was not elected to that office now
she comes from the world of business
she always says if it's true that she
turned around hewlett-packard not in the
right direction but she did turn it in a
direction and another women Oh Bruce
Jenner ah Bruce
the big interview is that I think it's
going on right now please no spoilers
i TiVoed it which is ironic because
sometimes my Tivo also cuts things off
its please what I meant to say is he's
an inspiration and inspiration to
thousands of people who have male jeans
but wear mom jeans it's an inspiration
hi kid the Kardashians you know they got
political this week did you see that
it's the hundredth anniversary of the
Armenian Genocide and there were meaning
and of course there was a demonstration
here today
I couldn't barely get to work I'm like
why us what did we do to the Armenians
but never there was a genocide a hundred
years ago they're right about that and
you know they're pissed off I don't
blame them that the United States will
not use the word genocide because we're
friends with Turkey who did it and sorry
we're not gonna upset Turkey but you
know who said it's a genocide the Pope
Pope is like [ __ ] yeah it's a genocide
haiya the Pope has huge balls you got to
admit that you would too if you were 78
and never had sex but of course the
woman who's really dominating the news
again this week is Hillary Clinton
because of another scandal the
Conservatives are saying this is the
worst Hillary scandal since whatever the
one last week was now this one is about
money apparently there's a new book out
called Clinton cash it alleges the
Clintons were you know using their
Charitable Foundation they got money
from that and then the foreign interests
would somehow get Hillary Clinton to
make decisions based on their needs as
Secretary of State she was at the time
whatever the [ __ ] I mean Hillary says
she has not read the book but it's on
her computer and she can't wait to
delete it
I tell you this a couple more months of
boring vague Hillary scandals we are
gonna be begging Bill Clinton to get
blown by an intern again that's my
prediction and I'm not saying that's not
a scandal there but you know what the
author is guy named Peter Schweitzer
he's a former policy adviser to Sarah
Palin he was the one who explained to
her that the blue stuff on the maps was
water you know I don't know if the
Clintons are hiding anything but if I
advise Sarah Palin on foreign policy I
would concentrate on burying that it's
like your resume saying I also dude
runnel drums
Donald Trump's hair you know
you're applauding me cuz I got that word
out thank you very much oh what a low
bar we're working with today well what's
going on meanwhile in the presidential
race I must say is horrifying I mean it
was bad enough when two small states
like New Hampshire and Iowa we're making
the decisions as kingmakers now it's
like we're down to like two
billionaire's who were doing this the
Koch brothers did you see this this week
okay first they said it was gonna be
Scott Walker and then oh whoops sorry
spoiler alert
too soon no no let's have a little more
of a do you know of an audition period
so now they announced their five
semi-finalists who got roses Scott
Walker Jeb Bush Ted Cruz Rand Paul Marco
Rubio those are the five and Bobby
Jindal agent called and said just meet
with him and the thousand year old
billionaire Sheldon Adelson he also has
picked the candidate he wants to shower
money on Marco Rubio and people said to
him Sheldon why Marco Rubio and he said
because Anna Nicole Smith is dead
Sheldon is this weekend hosting his
annual Republican Jewish coalition there
in Las Vegas at the hotel yawns they're
the venetian and george w bush is going
he's getting paid two hundred and fifty
thousand dollars he's not even speaking
he's just doing a DJ set by the pool and
unfor this is unfortunate for Sheldon he
picked a bad week had to do this because
you know he wanted all the presidential
hopefuls to come by but they're all in
Iowa because in Iowa this weekend I'm I
got to tell you it's the Iowa Faith and
Freedom Coalition spring dinner I answer
it's a big event very prestigious it's a
Rick Perry was told that it was
black-tie only and he said what we all
get cold
you